друзі Всіх вітаю останні два дні Путін і
його банда отримали два великих смачних
ляпаси від Сполучених Штатів Америки і
це безумовно приємно і важливо спочатку
Сполучені Штати Америки просто поставили
до відома російську сторону що
Американський президент Джо Байден в
рамках свого європейського турне
відвідує одну з європейських столиць
місто Київ Власне це був сьомий візит
політика байдена до України і перший
президента байдена Байден дуже добре
знає Україну підтримує її послідовно всі
ці роки і звичайно дуже добре посвячене
внутрішньоукраїнський контекст і нам
дуже повезло що президентом Сполучених
Штатів зараз є Байден який робить все
для того щоб Україна отримувала
підтримку зброю і його адміністрація
доклала максимум зусиль для формування
антипутінської коаліції Ну і звичайно
Наступного дня коли Путін готував це
звернення до держдуми доради Федерації В
цей же день у Варшаві лідер вільного
світу президент Байден звернувся до
гостей і жителів Польщі і звичайно це
було два абсолютно різних за стилістикою
і за подачею виступи як коли сказали
російські пропагандисти два міра два
образа жизни дві години невнятного цього
чавка І що Путін скло виступу перед
скучними і обрюшими мордами його банди
де вони самі сиділи засипали надто
вирізнявся від енергійного і дуже
такого емоційного виступу президента
байдена велику частину якого було
присвячено саме Україні Ну якщо
розбирати по цитатам Путіна то і не
згадаєш нічого нового це от
пережовування його маячні
псевдоісторичної про
цю історію України яку він там сам
вигадав І насправді він відмовляє
Україні в історії це все ці Повтори про
нациста в карателей неонацистов гостей
переворот Кровавый 14-го року ну тобто
маєш дня в якій живе Путін із якої він і
черпає цю свою агресію і виправдовування
щодо
анексії Криму і спроби захопити Україну
Якщо говорити про новини то мабуть що
одна тільки там і прозвучала це
знову-таки погрози
ядерною дубиною відновлення ядерних
випробувань і вихід Російської Федерації
із договору про стратегічне озброєння
але насправді ці його погрози вже мабуть
не лякають світ Це ми так очевидно що
російський режим піде так далеко як йому
дозволить світ І от в цьому контексті є
дуже важливим атмосфера і ці меседжі які
заклав У своєму виступі президент Байден
насправді дуже важливо що він кілька
разів повторив що Україна не залишиться
само сам на сам з російської Федерацією
світ буде стояти поряд Сполучені Штати
будуть стояти поряд І власне Росія має
програти Це очевидно уже для всіх тому
що в цивілізований світ з України Інше
питання що Україні потрібно зброя її
потрібно більше і вона має приходити
швидше тому що кожен день коли ми
залишаємося от з дефіцитом зброї це нові
втрати цивільних і військових
якщо дивитися на виступ Путіна ну
очевидно що після провалу бліцкрігу на
які сподівалися машина оця військова
російська потім Сьогодні має інший
сценарій - це затяжна війна війна
надовго війна на виснаження для того щоб
знекровити не тільки української
економіку а і зникрове підірвати
економіку світу Європейського Союзу
Сполучених Штатів сформувати в тому від
України і для того щоб Україна
залишилась без підтримки А можливо він
ставиться робить ставку і на заморожений
конфлікт дуже важливо не дати Путіну
реалізувати цей сценарій і тому ми дуже
сподіваємося що після
візиту президента байдена до України
підтримка буде зростати в першу чергу
військова для того щоб якомога швидше
припинити цю війну припинити її можна
тільки поразкою Російської Федерації
Тому так важливо зброя тому так важливі
реальні санкції і звичайно створення
трибуналу де вся ця банда має
відповідати ну власне звичайно українці
злотішаються ляпасами Які отримав
мурдяця Путін але має ще більше хочемо
бачити його в міжнародному журналів в
класі І от саме над цим треба працювати
і нам і нашим партнерам сподіваюсь так і
буде